(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners...
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
what if I were
to give you $150,000
and just buy you out?
Whoa.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You could make a lot,
a lot of money.
I can buy you happiness.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
This is a very serious
problem that happens.
Why is the government
not all over this?
It's sink...
you think it's worth
a million dollars.
Yes.
Not a chance in hell.
Or swim.
I can easily make you
millionaires.
Mark, I think that was
the fastest deal
we've ever done.
(laughs)
Next?
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
(man) First into the tank
are Jeffrey Simon
and Marc Newburger,
with a business
to help make sure
that nothing ever
slips through the cracks.
Howdy, sharks,
I'm Marc Newburger...
and I'm Jeffrey Simon,
and our company is...
(together) Drop stop!
We're here today
seeking a $300,000 investment
in exchange for
a 15% stake in our company.
Now, sharks, let me
ask you a question--
Have you ever dropped anything
down that gap
between the seat
and center console in your car?
You know what
I'm talking about--
That black hole,
that dark abyss,
the pit of doom.
What we like to call
the car-muda triangle.
(laughs)
That place that eats up
your cell phone,
your keys, loose change,
parking and credit cards,
and all sorts of food items,
like the French fry.
Tell me.
How many of you have
a 2-year-old
petrified French fry
sittin' down in that gap?
Who hasn't struggled, gotten
on their hands and knees,
Butt up in the air,
trying to retrieve
what just fell down there?
Well today,
your crack problems are over...
car seat crack, that is.
Introducing drop stop--
the first-of-Its-kind,
original patented safety device
designed to once and for all
block that pesky,
yet ever-so-dangerous gap
between your car seat
and center console.
Drop stop
reduces driver distraction
by Keeping your eyes
on the road, not in your gap.
Drop stop is universal
to fit any car or truck.
The built-In slot is designed
to fit easily
around the seat belt catch
like so...
Which anchors it
to the seat...
(Robert laughs)
So it can never
fall through to the floor.
And wherever your seat goes,
drop stop follows.
The stretchy,
durable material
is designed to last the life
of your vehicle and beyond,
and drop Stop's squishy center
allows it to expand or contract
to fit any size gap.
You won't even know
it's there...
till it stops the drop.
So, sharks, we can make
a lot of money together.
But we can also save
a lot of lives together.
So we're asking y'all
just this once
to lay down your dorsal fins
and join us to make
dropping and driving...
(together)
a thing of the past.
(laughs)
How much money is there
in solving
the car-Muda triangle problem?
We have actually sold
over 260,000 units.
You've sold 260,000 units?
Yes.
130,000 sets,
or 260,000 units.
How many dollars
did that equate to?
Uh, we have had gross sales,
since we opened our doors
in 2009, of $1.3 million.
This year,
how much will you do?
This year, we have made
$300,000 in gross sales,
and we have net $50,000.
For the fourth quarter,
which is one of
our biggest times of the year,
we have commitments
and things are in the works
to actually gross $500,000.
And from that, we will be making
$260,000 net income.
What is your mode of selling?
Where are you selling this?
We sell on our web site,
we sell through the catalogs,
and, Marc, where's
the other big one
we've been working on?
Well, we've actually had
42 shows on qvc.
And I'm speaking to
the queen herself right here.
And we--
42 times
it's been on qvc?
Yes. We just
had two shows last week,
in fact, we had
one scheduled for today...
today.
That we had to skip,
unfortunately, because--
This is much cooler
than qvc.
We love qvc. We love qvc.
That's right.
Everybody loves qvc.
(laughs)
Can we see 'em, guys?
Yeah.
Absolutely. Marc,
please give it to them.
With the packaging.
Yeah, with the packaging.
Are people that big slobs
that they're dropping stuff
in their car all the time?
Have you never dropped
anything down that gap before?
Even just could be
your phone, your keys.
I mean, everybody says,
"why didn't
I think of this idea?"
or, "god,
this happened to me."
Really?
This is a very serious
problem that happens.
The United States
department of transportation
said There are
over 500,000 accidents
and over 5,000 fatalities
that happen
from driver distraction
alone.
And, Marc,
why don't you share
how we actually
came up with the idea,
and I think that'll help...
okay.
You know.
About four and a half years ago,
we both live in Los Angeles,
I was driving
on sunset boulevard,
and my phone was just
sitting on the center console.
And when it rang, it shimmied
off and fell down the gap,
and I went to go
reach for it really quick,
and I tugged
the wheel to the right.
I looked up,
all four tires went up
onto the sidewalk,
I literally saw a guy
superman-leap
3 feet out of the way--
I would have killed him--
And I missed hitting
a telephone pole by an inch.
Wow.
And I just
started screaming,
"why doesn't somebody
come up with a way
to block this stupid crack?!"
there has to be a better way!
(laughs)
I agree!
What's it cost to make these,
and what do you sell 'em for?
Our cost to us is $4.
For one or two?
For a set of two.
For two.
$2 apiece.
And for retail,
it sells for $19.99.
So we're talking about
a markup of $5,
which we know is a very
attractive number to investors.
And you have to sell it
to retailers for $10.
Right.
Hold on.
I'm not there yet,
but I will get to that.
(Lori laughs)
Obviously, retailers
want a 50% markup.
So we sell it for $10.
We're making a gross profit
of $6.
Retail is the next big game,
which is why we're really here.
Do you have
intellectual property?
We have a patent.
(Lori) a utility patent.
A utility patent.
On?
On the actual product,
drop stop.
On putting stuff between a seat
and a center console?
An elongated member
with--With a slot that goes
around the seat belt catch.
(laughing)
We--We own that area, baby.
And--And there have been...
you are a sick puppy.
(laughs)
I can't believe people
are dropping that much stuff.
Like, it never happens to me.
Robert, just go out there
and look in my car.
(laughs)
(laughs) Thank you.
I'm not a believer
in the product.
I'm not the right investor.
I'm out.
Thank you, anyway.
Respectfully,
we understand that.
Thank you.
You know,
I-I like the story.
I think you guys
are making money.
I mean, where I'm from,
that--That space
is really, really special.
Because when somebody
pulls you over,
you can get three to five
on rikers island
if you don't have that space
to drop something down there.
(laughter)
Thankfully,
that hasn't happened yet.
I'm not saying that I ever
did anything like that.
Um, the--the sales are
showing that it's a need,
but it's not something
that I believe in.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Guys, I think
it's a phenomenal product.
I'm gonna take
the one you gave me,
and I'm gonna use it,
you know?
Because I'm--I'm a slob.
(laughs)
But being a slob, and being
a customer for the product
is different than being
the right person
to help you sell it.
You know, you've
already got qvc,
and Lori's
the right person for that.
So if I could
add value, I would,
but, guys,
I have to say I'm out.
Okay.
That's a bummer.
Bummer.
For me,
this isn't just a product.
It's a dream.
It is a calling.
If you can just
save someone's life once,
it's worth it.
I see the value, guys.
I really, really do.
Um, but it takes
a commitment to do it right.
I would be nothing more
than a checkbook to you guys,
and you guys are asking
for more than that.
Absolutely, and thank you
for being honest.
Yeah.
I like being a checkbook.
(both laugh)
I like to hear that.
Yeah.
You know, I think
the problem with this deal
is it's not really a company.
It's a product.
Right now what it does is,
it uses capital.
The bigger it grows,
it just sucks cash.
The bigger you get,
the more distribution you get,
the more money
you're gonna need.
Now for the investor,
Mr. Checkbook here--
Mr. Wonderful checkbook,
you can call me that--
I look at it
and say to myself,
"okay, I'll give you
$300,000."
You know, and right now that
money is hanging onto my leg,
it's saying,
"daddy, where am I going?"
I say, "nowhere yet.
I'm thinking about it.
You may go
to summer camp now."
It says, "no, daddy, no!
I wanna make sure I come home."
(laughs)
And so I'm thinking
to myself,
before I send
these little soldiers off,
I gotta figure out a way
that they come home
with more friends.
The idea is
send the dollars out,
they capture some,
they come back to daddy.
That's how it works.
So I give you the $300,000,
I don't want
any equity in your company.
But what I want is,
every time you sell
one of these foam weenies,
I get $2 back.
I mean, that would
end up leaving us
with a dollar
left for ourselves
after it's said and done,
if we're making $3
on each individual drop Stop.
Yeah, it's okay.
You're growing market share.
Well, you know, they say
money can't buy happiness.
And I agree. But...
I can easily
make you millionaires.
♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Jeffrey and Mark have an offer
from Kevin O'Leary
of $300,000 for a $2 royalty
on each unit sold.
But Lori
also seems interested.
They say
money can't buy happiness.
And I agree. But...
I can easily
make you millionaires.
I can get you
into retailers,
across the country
and internationally.
And so I'm going
to make you an offer.
I'm going to offer you
the $300,000.
But I'm going to ask
for 20%,
because I understand
what it's going to take
for me to do all of this.
But I think
you guys are a hero,
and I think the product's
a real hero.
Thank you.
And I'd love for you
to say "Yes" right now.
Can you imagine how much equity
you're giving up?
Boy, that hurts.
20%?
A lot.
I'm thinking I'll make it
more interesting for you.
I'll do it with my offer
because I am Mr. Wonderful,
let's remember that.
You are.
Instead of keeping
the $2 royalty on
after I recoup my capital,
it drops to $1.
Here--We need a moment,
right now, of money meditation.
Close your eyes.
Take a deep breath.
Visualize yourself sailing
on a boat with me
around Martha's Vineyard
next year.
Me handing you a check
for millions of dollars.
Now open your eyes...
and take the offer.
You're giving up equity,
which is very expensive
when one day, somebody
wants to buy this company.
Correct.
Lori, the Savage,
took 20% for herself.
But really,
she's really good for qvc,
but what's she gonna do
for retail?
If you don't make
a decision right now,
I swear I'm gonna
throw the weenie at you.
(both laugh)
on behalf
of both of us, Lori,
we would love
to be partners with you.
Whoo-Hoo!
Thank you.
Aah! Almost fell
on the weenie.
That almost fell
down the gap! (laughs)
So excited. It's great.
We're so excited.
Thank you so much
for understanding and believing.
Whoo! Lori!
Lori, you'll make
a lot of money with this.
I agree.
This is a great product.
Lori, we will be
sailing with you
on that boat
at Martha's Vineyard.
I cannot wait.
♪♪
Just months ago,
we saw Maria Curcio
and Veronica perlongo
make a deal
with all five sharks
for their early bed bug
detection system, buggybeds.
Yes or No?
Can we take one minute?
No.
(Kevin and Barbara)
don't even think about it.
It's a deal.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
So many amazing things have
happened since "Shark tank."
We brought our sales
from $150,000
to $1.2 million in 2 months.
Another 32 promises.
Aw, awesome.
Prior to "Shark tank,"
we were in home depot
in New Jersey state only,
about 60 stores.
Because of the airing
of "Shark tank,"
when people saw the product,
they were running out
to home depot do buy it.
Because
of the customer demand,
we are now rolling out in
600 stores across the country.
Every time
we go into the store,
we still get goosebumps
and such a great feeling
of pride
seeing out product
on the shelf.
Life after "Shark Tank"
has really changed for us.
I mean, we went
from working in our garage
to now running
a full warehouse.
We've been able to hire
over 50 employees so far.
We're signing on retailers
and distributors
almost on a daily basis
from around the world.
And we have "Shark tank"
to thank for that.
We got burlington
going on over here.
Since the show,
we gained instant credibility.
We're in
burlington coat factory,
walmart, walgreeens, almost
1,500 stores nationwide.
We're on target to reach between
7 and $10 million in sales.
And if all goes well,
we're gonna be the most
successful product
out of the tank.
♪♪
Next into the tank
are Dave Johnson
and Gary Groomes,
who have a unique solution to
a looming ecological problem.
Hi. I'm Dave Johnson,
president and founder
of traditional fisheries.
And I'm Gary groomes,
vice president.
We need $225,000 in exchange
for a 25% share.
We need your help
to fight a war
against
an environmental terrorist--
the lionfish. The worst invasive
Marine species in history,
capable of causing an economic
and ecological disaster.
Long prized for its beauty,
this exotic Fish
was imported from the Pacific
and sold
in Tropical fish stores.
Well, about 20 years ago,
somebody dumped
and handful of them
into the Atlantic ocean.
Since then, they've multiplied
like a supercomputer.
This map will demonstrate
the extent
of the lionfish spread
over the past 20 years.
You see, the lionfish,
because of its venomous spines,
has no natural predator.
And already, it is
the second most populous fish
in the western atlantic
and the caribbean.
And it eats
just about anything.
Right,
including valuable species,
like snapper, grouper, lobster,
shrimp, and crab,
that thousands of fisheries
and millions of people
depend on for survival.
And it gets worse.
Now they also feast on fish
that are crucial to keeping
Coral reefs alive.
Our oceans
are already in crisis.
And the lionfish
could be the straw
that breaks the camel's back.
But, sharks, we have
a solution to this problem.
Mm-hmm.
(together) to beat 'em,
just eat 'em.
Oh, chef Jeffrey?
Would you come out here, please?
(laughs) Oh, no.
The sharks are feeding.
Oh...
no.
No.
That's right, folks.
Today we are serving lionfish.
It's delicious, nutritious,
and perfectly safe to eat,
I assure you.
What would you liken it to?
What type of fish,
the way it tastes?
I would say it's similar
to snapper or grouper.
Chicken.
Chicken? (laughs)
So you are selling it?
Oh, absolutely, yeah.
And what do you call it
when you sell it?
We call it lionfish.
Why? Like sea Bass wasn't
originally called sea Bass.
It had some nasty name
for whatever...
patagonian toothfish.
Yeah,
the patagonian toothfish.
There you go. Right.
Right. Right. Yeah.
Sea Bass sure sounds
a whole lot better.
Well, you're right, mark.
In that regard,
it does sound better.
But on the other hand, uh,
we're promoting this as
an opportunity for people
to help the ecology
by consuming the fish.
So that's why we wanted
to keep the name lionfish.
But, mark, if you
wanna give us money,
we'll call it
anything you want.
We'll--We'll call it
the cubanfish.
(laughs) It tastes good.
I mean, do you guys like it?
Yeah.
Yeah, I mean,
it tastes like, uh...
flounder.
Delicious.
I'm familiar with
the lionfish from aquariums.
'cause it's
a very beautiful fish.
Until you told me today
that it's a danger
to all the other fish,
I never realized that.
(Mark) Yeah.
The fact that it has
no predators.
It's proliferating
in the caribbean,
and there's just
no stopping that.
And you're saying that's bad
for the underwater environment?
It eats snapper.
It eats the herbivorous fish.
How does that little guy
eat a lobster?
Lobster larvae.
But doesn't every fish
eat lobster larvae?
It sounds like a delicacy.
Yeah, it does sound
like a--
Yeah.
I would guess that
every fish does, but--
So aren't we being
a little negative on this guy?
(mark laughs)
No, we're not.
Trust me, Kevin.
But I'm amazed that this
is so delicious.
I'm-a go home to my fish tank
and Lemon and tartar up,
uh... ol' skippy.
(laughter)
But let me ask you
something.
Yeah, sure.
If they taste that delicious,
why haven't anybody else
harvested this, uh,
fish out of the sea?
It's very labor intensive.
It's taken us a long time
and it's cost us
a lot of money.
What's the process
of catching them?
They don't bite on a hook,
and they live in caves
of the reef.
Of the reefs, yeah.
So you can't net them.
So they're only speared.
And we deal with, uh,
mexican spearing cooperatives.
How can you scale it if you
have to Spear each one of 'em?
There's a surprising number
of, uh,
Spear fishing cooperatives
in the caribbean.
So how does the cost
of the fish per pound
compare to other fish,
like sea Bass or Trout
or whatever?
It would comparable
to probably sea Bass,
grouper, uh, snapper.
So there's not really
a cost element here?
So you've really gotta
like the taste
and be willing to choose it
and possibly be willing
to choose your dinner
based off of some
ecological factors?
That and the taste.
I mean...
how does the consumer know
they should eat this?
Well, that's been a challenge,
because we essentially
are introducing a new fish
into the U.S. Market.
But, Dave, if this is
such a problem,
why is the government
not all over this?
I've never seen anything
of this danger.
You're telling me
that the reefs are gonna die.
Robert, I honestly think
the problem is
a lack of funding right now
because so many programs
have been cut.
At least that's what
we're hearing
from the people that we talk to
in the government.
So let's go to the business
side of it.
How much fish have you sold
in the last year?
Um, we've grossed $12,000.
Sales?
Yes.
Sales.
Boy, is that ever small.
Let me tell you where I stand.
I think you have a tremendous
market acceptance problem
ahead of you.
You did a good job of explaining
the problem, but...
Mm-hmm.
I don't care how much supply
you have if there's no demand.
I'm out.
All right. Well, thanks
for your time, Robert.
So, on cape cod
at the turn of the century,
the lobster was considered
the cockroach of the sea.
Mm.
Nobody would eat it.
That's why they fed it
to prisoners.
It took 40 years
to convince Boston society
that that cockroach
was a delicacy,
and now it trades
for, you know,
$15 a pound sometimes
in restaurants.
40 years is a long time.
Now, that little cockroach
May take just as long
to convince people to eat it.
You'll both be dead
before that's mainstream.
I won't be,
'cause I'm a vampire.
(laughter)
But in the meantime, I'm out.
All right. Thanks for your time,
Kevin. Appreciate it.
Guys, I think this is
just gonna be a huge
educational challenge,
and, uh,
$225,000 is just not
gonna do it.
I'm out.
Thank you.
All right, thanks, daymond.
It is a good problem
to solve.
It is
a high leverage problem,
meaning that if you can
solve it,
you can make a lot,
a lot, a lot of money.
But your catch-22 is
it's gonna take a lot of money.
You really haven't asked
for enough to solve a problem.
You haven't said, "look,
"This is how we're gonna
market it
just to one community
to--to find the demand."
So I'm out.
Thanks.
Thank you, mark.
I'm for anything that helps
the ecology,
and I hope that some kind
of solution happens
in a more global way
with More help
than just the two of you.
But I can't see people
running to eat lionfish.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, thank you all
for your time.
Good luck, guys.
Very much so.
Good luck.
Congratulations, too.
It was very interesting.
Bye-Bye.
It's a beautiful fish.
I want to go see
that fish.
I know. They're great
in aquariums.
They're so cool.
Look at the--look at
the tips on those spines.
It's beautiful.
It's also quite unattractive
when it's Fried up.
It's primordial.
I love the fish.
I think it's beautiful.
I didn't realize it was
such a big problem.
He's not looking
so good now.
We didn't get a deal,
but we're gonna move forward
and we're gonna fight
this damn fish.
There's more lionfish
in the sea today
than there were yesterday.
And that's gonna continue
to happen
until somebody does
something about it.
♪♪
My name is Lani Lazzari,
I'm 18 years old,
I'm from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
and I'm the C.E.O.
and president
of simple sugars.
Hi, everyone.
Hey, Lani.
I was born to be
an entrepreneur.
I wanted to go over these
sales numbers with you.
When I was in third grade,
I started selling
hair scrunchies
out of my backpack
to my friends at school,
and that was just the beginning.
A few years later
when I was 11,
I started simple sugars.
Simple sugars products provide
a high-end
skin care experience,
while also being
completely all natural
and safe for even
the most sensitive skin.
Tie the bow on,
trim it up,
and give it to me, and I'll
pack 'em into the box.
Ever since the beginning,
I've always been the one
really running this business.
I have gone
to all my own meetings,
negotiated all my own deals,
even from the time
when I was 11.
I know. Oh, Kate!
(laughter)
My family is so important to me,
especially my mom.
Sports is not your thing.
(laughs)
Yeah, I know.
She drove me to every meeting
until I could get
my driver's license,
and she's been behind me
supporting me all the way.
I need an investment
from the sharks because
Simple Sugars has grown
as much as it can
with how we've been able
to fund it.
We've been bootstrapping
this business on credit cards,
and now we really need
to put a little bit of money
behind it to be able
to capitalize on its growth.
I've risked a lot
to make my dream come True.
I've had to give up
my good grades in high school,
my friends, a lot of
my childhood experiences.
So getting a deal
from the sharks
would really make it all
worth it.
♪♪
Hi. My name is Lani Lazzari.
I'm from
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania,
and my company
is Simple Sugars.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
I started simple Sugars
almost seven years ago
when I was 11 years old.
Since infancy, I've suffered
from horrible eczema.
I couldn't find
a single product that I could
safely use
on my sensitive skin,
let alone one
that actually smelled good.
So, as a determined
11-year-old,
I started doing research
and got to work
creating the product
I was looking for.
My homemade creation
not only took away my eczema,
but it also cleared up
my Aunt's psoriasis.
Soon I was getting requests
from my friends and family
to buy my products.
I couldn't pass up
the opportunity
to become a businesswoman,
despite the fact that I wasn't
even a teenager yet.
Simple Sugars products are
all-Natural sugar scrubs.
They gently exfoliate,
providing deep moisture
and complete skin nourishment
in one easy step.
The result is super smooth,
great-Looking skin
without using a laundry list
of products.
Up until this point,
I've been growing simple sugars
while simultaneously being
a high school student.
Now that I've graduated,
I'm ready to do
whatever it takes
to blow the lid off this thing.
But I need a little help.
That's where you guys come in.
Lori, I would love it
if you would come up
and try out the products.
Now, I have three of
our bestselling body scrubs
to choose from.
Would you like to try
strawberry, coconut,
or lemonade?
Uh, strawberry.
Okay.
Here, take a smell.
Ooh, that smells great.
S--
Gonna give you a little
bit of water.
She might melt.
(laughter)
I'm gonna give you
a little bit of scrub.
Okay. So now you
want to scrub
until it feels like the sugar
crystals start to melt.
They have a very small
crystal size,
which means that sugar is
a very gentle exfoliant,
so it's safe
for sensitive skin.
They're
completely all-natural.
They have no
artificial colorings,
preservatives, scents,
anything in them.
All of the oils are chosen
because they're safe
for sensitive skin, and also
because they absorb quickly,
so you're left feeling
smooth and not greasy.
So... wanna dry 'em off?
And how do they feel?
It feels very, very soft.
Yeah.
So that's the oils in it?
The--
that's the oils in it.
The sugar removes the barrier
of dead skin cells
that naturally sits on top
of your skin...
smells great.
Which allows the oils
to penetrate into your skin
and provide that moisture.
Where have you been
selling this?
60% of our sales are on
the simple sugars Web site.
Okay.
But we also do
wholesale as well.
And we are in our largest
local high-End grocery chain.
What are your sales, Lani?
Our sales year-to-date
are $55,000.
What do you think you'll do
this calendar year?
This calendar year,
we're projecting
very conservatively
$100,000.
What do you think
you'll make on it?
Our profit margins
are 75% to 80%.
But you're not paying yourself
anything yet?
Sometimes I take
a small salary--
Um, $400 a month--When we
have the cash flow for it.
Couple gummi bears, Yeah.
Yeah. (laughs)
(Robert) Lani,
I'm more interested
than the money right now--
How did you come up
with the formulas?
Like, uh, like the chemistry
behind it?
I was more aware
of skin care products
than the average 11-year-old,
'cause I was always
at the dermatologist's office
with all of these problems.
So I started doing research,
and, to be honest,
I just got obsessed with it.
So I just started,
through trial and error,
making products
and trying them on myself.
You don't have
any mainstream distribution.
You're a niche player
online.
You have $100,000 in sales.
But it's not worth
a million dollars.
Now, tell me why--
I don't care what age you are.
If you bring out here
a million-dollar valuation,
you gotta defend it.
Yes.
So defend it.
I am willing to negotiate
on that,
but there are a few things
I'd like you to consider first.
In 2010, I was a sophomore
in high school.
My sales were $13,000.
At that point, I decided
that I wanted to actually
focus on growing
this business.
So I basically took
the whole year off
to work full-time
on growing the business.
As a result of my efforts
that year,
my sales grew to $38,000,
a 192% increase,
and I did all of that
by myself
with no funding and no help
as a high school student.
Now, in the past three months
since I've graduated
and been able to work
full-time,
I have grown simple sugars'
retail presence
from 6 stores to 20.
I've made it
the top-Selling specialty brand
in our local high-End
grocery chain,
and I'm in the process
of negotiating
a deal worth
$150,000 to $400,000
over the next two years
with a high-End online
Skin care retailer.
You said that it cured
your own eczema and psoriasis.
It's really hard to be able
to make a claim like that.
We don't make any claims
about what the product
will do for you.
What we do talk a lot
about is the benefits
of each individual
ingredient,
which is something
you can say.
But we can't make any claims
about it curing eczema
or psoriasis. I can only
speak from my experience.
What does your dermatologist
say when you go back to him
or her and present this
to them,
and is he recommending--
Or her--recommending it
to his other patients?
Oh, yes, definitely.
She uses the products.
She loves them.
'cause I have three kids,
and my wife literally
would come and make
your bed every day...
yes.
I would, too, for that matter,
if it kept my--My son
in particular from itching
all over.
(laughs)
Yes.
Well, it's a huge problem.
There are 30 million people
in the United States
that have eczema,
and 52% of the population
describes themselves
as having sensitive skin.
We heavily market it
as a product for sensitive skin.
That's something that
we can say.
And you're allowed to say that?
Right.
Oh, yes. We're perfectly
allowed to say that.
It is one of the hardest things
you could do with your life,
starting a business,
being an entrepreneur.
Oh, yes.
What inspired you to start
your own business?
When I was much younger,
my mom went on maternity leave
with my youngest brother.
And while she was away
on maternity leave,
she got passed over
for a promised promotion.
At that point,
I was very discouraged,
especially as a woman,
about one day
going into
the corporate world.
So from that point on,
I decided
that I wanted to be
an entrepreneur
so I could be responsible
for my own success.
I was the same way.
I didn't want to be
under control
of somebody else.
I wanted to lead
my own destiny.
Yes.
And I am super impressed that
you are doing what you're doing.
I-I do want to know what--what
are you gonna do with the money?
$50,000 is going to go towards
hiring 2 part-time salespeople
to support
our initial accounts.
Because right now I'm focusing
too much of my time
on supporting the accounts
we already have,
and not enough time
on seeking out larger accounts.
And where are you currently
making the goods and--
is this all out of your house?
No, not anymore.
We have a facility
in pittsburgh.
Everything is made there,
and that's also
where we have our offices.
I have three employees
who do all the manufacturing
of the products.
Uh, I really am questioning,
do you really need us,
or--Or me?
Because you're doing great.
You can grow yourself,
and I would not complement
your business,
and I think it would be,
um, counterproductive
for us to partner up
in that sense.
So, with that said,
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Lani, I love you.
I think you are amazing.
Amazing.
The quality's great.
It smells great.
I'm so impressed by you.
Thank you.
But...
♪♪
Lani, I love you.
I think you are amazing.
Amazing.
Thank you.
And the quality's great,
it smells great.
But for me, I think there's
too much competition
with scrubs out there,
so I'm not going to offer you
any money...
okay.
For this.
I'm out.
(Kevin) Okay, Lani.
Here's what I know
is a reality.
The cosmetics industry,
of which you're a part of,
is the most competitive
on earth. Why?
Because the only products that
have higher margins are illegal.
(chuckles) Yes.
(Lori chuckles)
It's virtually impossible
to get share
from the large companies
that own this space.
There's absolutely
nothing proprietary
of what you're doing
at all.
It's so simple to do that
even an 11-year-Old can do it,
and apparently has.
Yes.
But what really strikes me is,
you think it's worth
a million dollars.
Yes.
Not a chance in hell,
no matter how wonderful
your story is.
(chuckles)
I'm not interested. I'm out.
Lani, I think if the measure
of success in a business
was drive and passion,
your business would be
successful.
Yes.
I-I think my challenge
with it is
it is a very, very
difficult task
that you're trying to take on.
For me to give you
the $100,000,
I would have to negotiate
such a value from you,
that it's... unequitable
to you...
yes.
And it becomes
unequitable to me.
Yes.
And you don't want
to do that...
No.
And I don't want to do that
to you.
No, and--
So on this investment,
I'm out.
Four sharks are out.
Mark is Lani's last chance
for an investment.
I'm not an expert
in this market, obviously.
Yes.
All I know is the suffering
my kids go through.
Yes.
So I want you
to explain to me
for my 3-year-old son--
He's got it all right here
where his eczema is.
Mm-hmm.
What should he do?
What product should he be using?
Eczema is a scaly,
dry skin condition.
So gentle exfoliation
is really important
to helping alleviate it.
So the scrubs,
with the blend of the sugar
and the oils
that are in there--
That's especially what's good
to use on eczema.
So...
okay. Who do you see
as your primary competition,
and name the company name.
Fresh.
And why do you think they're
your primary competition?
Because they have
a very comparable product
quality-wise,
and most of the time,
we get customers
who come to us from
using a fresh scrub
and switch to our company,
because we are
more affordable than them.
I don't think we ever heard
the cost for your product.
They're $15.95
for the large size,
which is this size.
And how much does a comparable
fresh product cost?
$74.
And the cost
to make the scrub?
$3.61.
And how low do you think
you can get that cost?
Uh, I can cut it at least
in half by doubling the sales.
Mark, has she convinced you?
She's darn good.
Okay, here's what
I'm willing to do.
I'm willing
to invest $100,000...
okay.
For 33% of the company.
Okay.
And the reason why 33%
from where you are is,
there's gonna be considerable,
um, requirements of my time.
And I value my time.
I'd like to counter.
Okay.
Would you accept $100,000
for 25% equity?
No, I would not.
Okay. So you won't go
any lower than 33%?
No.
Mark... I would love
to accept your offer.
That's what I like to hear.
I'm very excited
to work together.
So am I. Congratulations.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Thanks, sweetie.
And please take some home
to your kids as Well,
so they can try it out.
Trust me, I'm already
grabbin' everybody's.
Great.
Thank you so much.
Thanks. Congratulations,
Lani.
Thank you.
(Lori) Congratulations.
(Mark) Nice job.
Thank you.
You're amazing.
She was one of the best pitchers
we've had here
at any age.
She was 18.
If that's our future,
we are in good hands.
We're in really good shape.
In the future, I hope
that I will be an inspiration
to other young entrepreneurs
and encourage them
to follow their dreams
and that if you're passionate
and you're committed,
you can do it.
♪♪
Next up is Jeffrey Miller,
who's hoping to resurrect
an old idea.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jeffrey Miller.
And my product
is called coolwraps.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 40% equity in my company.
Let me ask you a question--
When was the last time
you had fun gift wrapping?
Well, if you're
anything like me,
and I'm gift wrap-Challenged,
the answer is "Never"...
until now.
Allow me to introduce you
to coolwraps.
Coolwraps is
a shrink wrap gift bag
that is so easy to use.
We say it's as easy
as 1-2-3...
stuff it, Seal it,
shrink it.
Allow me to demonstrate.
Simply place a gift
into a bag.
Remove the protective film
from the adhesive strip.
Fold it over and close it
like you would an envelope.
And now with a hair Dryer,
you shrink it to fit.
(whirring)
Simply run the hair Dryer
around the present,
and you will instantly
see it start to shrink.
Have you noticed
there's no tape, no scissors,
no hassle,
and absolutely no mess?
It's amazing.
And in no time, you will have
a wonderfully wrapped gift.
(Dryer turns off)
Jeffrey, are those the ones
you did before?
Yes. I did all of these
last night.
And unlike regular
gift wrapping,
I had fun doing it.
I mean, coolwraps... (laughs)
Coolwraps is a great product,
and it's proven,
and it's great.
Um...
it is an amazing product.
I love it.
I'm passionate about it.
I mean, it's perfect
for everyone.
As I said, young and old,
male and female.
And if you have
dexterity issues, it's perfect.
This is a game-Changer now.
This is an amazing product.
Jeff, can you tell us
about the business?
This product was out on
the market about ten years ago.
Then what happened?
We were a partnership,
and we got it out
into the market,
we got on qvc twice,
and we sold out.
We got tested in cvs,
We went to the banks.
We needed money to roll it out,
and we couldn't get it.
We had purchase orders in hand.
And they just wanted us
to collateralize our homes.
They didn't care
about the orders.
Well, how much were you
asking for from the bank?
We needed, in order to fulfill
the larger quantities
that we were
getting orders for,
we needed $300,000
to $500,000.
Jeff, when the bank manager
was willing to lend you that
money--pretend I'm him--
I say, "Jeff, I'm very excited
"About your gift wrap bag,
shrink wrap, whatever.
"I hope you're as excited
as I am,
"because I'm gonna
lend you the money,
"and I'm gonna put
as a collateral your home.
"But you have
no problem with that,
because you believe
in the product."
I did.
But the partnership--
in total,
we had already put in
over $150,000 into it.
Why didn't the other partners
also believe
and be willing
to put up their homes?
Well, we didn't want--
This is the test
of a real entrepreneur.
I--absolutely.
Do you take the chance?
Do you bet it all?
I'm there with you.
Obviously, you weren't
there with him,
because you said No.
Why did you say no?
I didn't say no.
The consensus was no.
I wanted to bring in
venture capital.
What percentage
of the company did you own?
I was a 20% shareholder.
And so fast forward to today.
Yes.
How much of it do you own?
I own 100% of this.
But, Jeffrey, what happened
to the other partners?
Well, we couldn't
fulfill the orders,
they gave up,
and I acquired everything.
What's happened?
Why for ten years
did you do nothing with it?
I've not been able to get
in front of the right people.
I have been to trade shows,
I have tried
to get the word out there.
Did you stand there
with a blow Dryer,
sealing,
getting people excited?
Um, no. I went around
and tried to hand out my cards
and get--Give some...
Oh, my gosh.
So nobody saw
the product in action?
No.
Nobody knew
what you were really selling?
No.
So you didn't have a Booth?
You were just
going around trolling?
Correct.
I didn't--I didn't
have the money.
Jeffrey, you gotta--
You gotta demonstrate this.
I know.
Is there anything else
like this out on the market?
There is not. I have
a patent on it.
Not at all?
Nothing.
It's a utility patent?
It's a utility patent.
You cannot make
anything like this.
And how much does it cost you
to make one bag?
Um... on average...
on average.
Price is between
11 to 18 cents a bag.
And then what did you sell them
for when you sold them on qvc?
What was your offer?
Qvc was a 20-Pack,
and they had a special price
of--I think it was $16.88.
Have you called anybody
to try and license this?
No. I-I don't know
how to go about it,
and that's why
I need your help.
So you want us to bet
on a 10-year-Old product
'cause you think we'll
bring it back into the market,
and bingo--It'll come back.
Actually, I think--
I am so happy
that it's happening now,
because manufacturing processes
have improved.
We can bring cost down.
Jeff, it--It's great
that you love it,
but my gosh--ten years?
You--You've gotta
go and sell some.
And obviously,
you're not the sales guy.
I don't see the market.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
I'm not sure
about this product at all.
I think it has potential,
and I like
that you have a patent.
I also think
it's a good tv product,
but I think it needs
a lot of revamping.
So what if I were
to give you $150,000
and just buy you out?
Whoa.
You make $150,000.
The risk is mine.
Because I'm really not sure.
I don't like
that for ten years it sat.
But I'm willing
to take the Gamble.
You can continue
to do other things.
You don't have
a 10-year dinosaur.
And it becomes my problem
or my success.
I'll tell you what--
I'll give you $250,000
for the whole company...
and a 3% royalty,
but it's yes or no
right now.
Whoa.
Aggressive.
Look at these sharks circling.
Yes or no?
Mark, I accept your offer.
Done.
(Kevin) whoa!
I like the way you think.
Wow.
Congratulations.
You're a rich man.
Thank you very much.
How does it feel
to have 250 grand?
That's amazing.
Yes, it is. That's how we
do business, right?
Uhh. Done.
Lori, can I wrap
any presents for you?
Yes! (laughs)
Mark, I think that was
the fastest deal
we've ever done.
(laughs)
Next?